una noticia recibida con frialdad
Moscú aseguró que no ve como un problema
la adhesión de Finlandia y Suecia la
otan una solicitud formal ya en trámite
con el objetivo de obtener garantías en
materia de seguridad adicionales
incentivadas por la invasión del kremlin
de Ucrania el pasado 24 de febrero
no tenemos disputas territoriales con
ellos no hay nada que nos pueda
preocupar en términos de que Finlandia y
Suecia se conviertan en miembros de la
otan
pero algunos funcionarios rusos
aseguraron que las nuevas membresías a
la alianza del Atlántico Norte
aumentarán las tensiones en la región al
ser un esfuerzo desestabilizador Como
señaló el vicecanciller Ruso serguéi
reakov y el mandatario ruso Vladimir
Putin también advirtió que respondería
por la vía militar si estas naciones
acogen tropas e infraestructuras de la
otan en su territorio Y es que Finlandia
comparte 1300 kilómetros de frontera con
la federación rusa
seguros ahora si despliegan las tropas y
la infraestructura de la otan nos
veremos obligados a responder de la
misma manera y crear las mismas amenazas
todo iba bien entre nosotros pero ahora
habrá tensiones seguro que las habrá
esto es obvio e Inevitable repito si hay
una amenaza para nosotros
hasta el momento Putin había criticado
las intenciones de Finlandia y Suecia
acusando a la alianza de tener
ambiciones imperiales mientras que la
otan dejó Claro que no Busca la
confrontación con mos